the witcher games and the ultra popular
the witcher 3
the wild hunt in particular have given
many fans a very definitive depiction
of andres of kofki's mysterious
continent
and its many strange denizens as such
netflix's live-action adaptation of the
witcher
was always going to be a tough balancing
act how to recreate a world that
millions of players have already
obsessed over for countless hours
in a familiar yet fresh way how to
create the sense of danger that the
game's many powerful enemies
and monsters radiate and how oh how
could anyone hope to capture the gruff
energy of the main character
geralt of rivia though he's best known
for his comparatively clean-cut turn
as the dc extended universe version of
superman
cavill absolutely nails the essence of
geralt
the actor prepared extensively for the
role transforming his body
to better suit its needs and of course
delivering his lines with that signature
growl
however he has now revealed that one
important aspect in his character work
happened completely by accident yeah
that iconic voice
cavill uses in the witcher as he
revealed during cd project red and
netflix's virtual witcher con
it was a total mistake on the actor's
part he simply forgot
what kind of voice he was supposed to
use part way through the shoot
and after he heard what he sounded like
in a scene with king foltest
he was delighted but also slightly
worried because he initially felt the
delivery was a bit too close
to voice actor doug cockles performance
in the witcher games
cavill said i know it's very similar to
doug cockle's amazing work that was
definitely a concern of mine
i thought well i don't want to seem like
i'm plagiarizing another professional's
extraordinary work
and i had a look at it how to listen to
it and i thought actually
they are different enough it's clearly
inspired by cockles version
but i did my own thing there was just
one problem they had already shot some
scenes for the show
fortunately the powers that be liked
cavill's new take on the voice
so much that they offered to reshoot the
scenes seeing as the combination of
geralt's harsh voice
strange accent and quiet nature play a
large part in his characterization
it's probably fair to say that this was
the right call
series creator lauren schmidt his rick
knew that the role of geralt
would be one quite sought after but she
also knew that she was going for a
certain iconic voice to bring the
character to the screen
his rick told us here at looper at the
end of the day though
i realized that i actually kind of had
henry cavill's voice in my head
and i called him and explained basically
this whole thing
so although he found his geralt voice by
a happy accident
the actor's voice was a factor before he
was even officially cast for the show
nevertheless cavill refused to outright
accept the part
as he shared his rick's philosophy that
the production
should seek far and wide for its geralt
hissrick said
and he was like great if you want me i
want you to know that i am the right
person i want you to have seen
everyone and met everyone and we met up
again and we talked for several hours
and by the time we left that day i knew
that i had found
our geralt in the end cavil ended up
coming out on top in a casting process
that hysteric said involved 207
potential geralts
and that was before the actor even found
the character's iconic voice
not bad check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
witcher are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one